well finding an affordable rental in the
valley is not easy yeah according to
rent.com the average price for a one
bedroom but fifteen hundred dollars in
the las vegas area joe muller telling us
that's what's forcing some people to
look elsewhere
joe well if you're looking for an
apartment or rental you know it's not
easy at all to do it's pretty difficult
to find right now apartment rentals and
prices are increasing and because of
this a renter i spoke with has no choice
but to move
[Music]
while rent is on the rise around the
nation here in the valley it's going up
really fast apartmentlist.com shows las
vegas area rent went up 26 percent in
2021
all corners of the valley are seeing the
increase i spoke to patrice davis in the
northeast valley her rent went up 200
dollars in september i'm going to start
looking probably next month to move
somewhere else like to find you know a
cheaper
place that you know i better afford
rent.com shows the average one bedroom
in las vegas was not even 1200 a year
ago industry experts say they don't see
a decline anytime soon as demand for
rentals continues to climb as well
now back out here live while the average
in the vegas area according to rent.com
is about 1500 bucks it's still pretty
affordable compared to other cities
around the country new york for example
the average one bedroom there is around
3 700 bucks a month reporting live joe
mohler live local now